for 16 days I know
many people are feeling tired now I
understand it
I understand
it's
all about emotions and
it's life when we mobilize our
efforts and when we see that we can win
we expect
the enemy full quicker but the truth is
this is the war this is the fight we
need more time we need more patience
we need to be wise
we need to do our job the best we can
to gain the victory we can't say how
many more days
we will need to
take our land back but we can do it
because we want to do it we already have
strategic Victory we're already on the
way to the victory this is our Patriotic
War
they destroyed residential houses in
Sumo region they continue torturing
Mario pull
Ivana frankiewsk they targeted this
place as well
so they carry on their
Invasion and that's why we require
further more rigid sanctions against
Russia because they must pay for what
they do every day they must pay
European Union has to do more to
implement a decision to do more for
Ukraine for the European Union for
everyone All European nations expect
this to happen